the manchester mayor andy burnham has
just told this program that
scrapping hs2 would mean an almighty
fight with the cities of the north
the man ultimately responsible is the
new transport secretary grant shaps he's
just announced that new 3d scanners must
be installed in airports by the end of
2022
which could lead to the end of the ban
on liquids in cabin baggage well grant
chaps is with us now
um let's start off with the announcement
today um my understanding is that
this was already in the pipeline
heathrow doing it jfk are doing it you
just
piggybacking on something that's already
gonna happen yeah i mean the technology
moves on doesn't it and
these 3d scanners which are like the ct
scanners that people
go into when they're having um you know
a medical
issue have been being developed um
what's new is we've said we actually
want this in
all of our airports and sort of set a
deadline for all the major airports set
a deadline for that to happen
i went to see these on thursday where
they're already
in operation and it is amazing it means
you're not having to faff around with
those plastic bags that's all out the
window
eventually not yet but eventually there
won't be restrictions
necessarily on the amount of liquids you
can take that 100 milliliter
restriction will go you won't have to
take your laptop out your ipad out
it's actually going to make the whole of
going through security a lot smoother i
think it also sends an important message
britain's open for business we're going
to make it easier for people to come and
go i think it's a big message too and
it's safer
other reports in the sunday papers today
that i'm keen to ask you about
that there is going to be a cut to fuel
duty
in an emergency budget in october that
would be the first cut for eight years i
think i mean is that something you want
to see happen
i don't want to disappoint you by by not
coming here and giving you the result of
a budget that's not even being
planned yet um so i mean is it something
that you would like to
see happen so i'm really keen on you
talking about petrol um
uh side of things yes yeah i'll tell you
what i really like to happen
um is 27 of all the country's co2
comes from transport 90 of that's from
vehicles so actually if we can move to
electric cars we will make the biggest
difference so actually
fuel duty is not where you should be you
have to accept that most people at the
moment are not in electric vehicles
there's a long shift to go but if you
want to
know my long-term view it's um let's get
you know electric vehicles running
everywhere i think we'll get to the
point
where people will look back and go
remember when we used to have sort of
um gas guzzling you know petrol and
diesel
pumping out when actually um you know
electric cars don't permit any um co2
there are now more electric charges
locations than there are petrol stations
so you know that's a big move
but on your tax question on on fuel when
you get the chancellor on make sure
you're asking
i will you'll be interested in the
answer as well by the sounds of it um
with all these policy announcements you
know the the trail of the fugiti fuel
duty cart you know you've got the
airport scanners i mean it feels like
we're on an election footing
we are on an election putting up look i
think the simple truth is they
we need to get brexit done that is
number one and
um 31st of october but all these
whatever else aren't about brexit are
they they're these announcements are
punter
friendly policies it feels to me
specifically geared up
for uh potentially i think some of it
may be over interpreting there hasn't
been an announcement about fuel for
example
um well someone's told numerous sunday
papers about it well i mean the
newspapers often feel lots of stuff i
don't think
you know you will people know this i
don't think it necessarily means
anything at all
um things like the scanners uh you know
this is getting on with
the business of government and to be
absolutely clear um
i know this because i sit in the the
brexit exit preparation meetings in
cobra
rooms every virtually every day of the
week we are massively preparing for the
one
big significant moment 31st of october
where we have to leave
where we will leave and we will be
prepared as prepared as it is
possible beyond that i can't say but
that is the number one priority okay
now i've got a really simple question
that i hope you'll be able to answer
try me me directly is hs2
going to happen so we'll know the answer
to this by the end of the year
i've asked doug okovi with the longer
the prime minister to do review
i've said blank sheet of paper i've just
come into this role
blank sheet of paper just give me the
facts so it could be scratched
everything is possible so it may be it
may be that after this review
you decide to scrap hs2 if you start
with a blank piece of paper and you say
to the person doing the review
and his team give me the facts then any
outcome is possible from that yes
but andy burnham has just said on the
program earlier that if that happens
you're going to have an almighty battle
with cities in the north and he's not
the only person who's worried i just
want to have a look
at some of the reaction to this review
this is the leader of birmingham city
council in ward
a u-turn would be disastrous let's have
a look
at some of the other ones chief
executive of the liberal bid bill added
this latest announcement once again
spreads doubt
uncertainty and frustration among
business leaders in the north
and finally the mayor of the west
midlands the conservative mayor of the
wesleyan midlands andy street
hs2 is mission critical for the west
midlands i mean have you had an angry
call from andy street
no i have not um but angie street will
be helping on the review so he'll be
feeding in his
views along with many other people some
form some like lord berkeley against
um and look i mean i met with andy
burnham my very first
saturday in the job when the prime
minister went up to manchester
made the announcements that come what
may we will be building
a high-speed link between manchester and
leeds i believe in
that these are these rail links also at
the minute depend on hs2 i mean if you
just have to look for example at barry
white chief executive transport for
north i mean he's designing the northern
powerhouse rail
he says the current plan is effectively
contingent on hsd
so i also met with barry as well and let
me be clear the prime minister said the
same
like we would hesitate for an age before
uh not building big infrastructure but
it must be right and all of these people
would agree with this
to check what we're doing just because a
project
has already taken a lot of money and
just because the you know projections
even if the projections just continue to
rise in terms of the costs
it cannot be right not to stop and take
a look at it
we are spending taxpayers money and that
money can only be spent once
so you've got to spend it wisely so this
is blank sheet of paper
let's take a look at it and i'll tell
you once i've got all the facts in front
of me what i
think about it but i want the facts
first and i'll be going back to
parliament
um when we return shortly um
and uh making a statement to say
everything i know
so far uh about about this as well
because i think it's just right to get
everything out on the table blank sheet
paper on hs2
what about third runway at heathrow is
that going to happen so on the third
runway i mean as you know parliament's
voted with
quite an overwhelming majority for it so
that's
do you want it to happen there we need
more southeast airport capacity
um it's absolutely true the prime
minister raised some
concerns about whether the whole thing
stacks up so i'll tell you what i'm
doing about it
um i want to know that if this goes
ahead it's privately funded so that
sounds
great the problem is eventually those
funds have to be
that money has to be sort of crawled
back and there's only one place it'll be
called back from
and that's the passengers so the whole
thing has to stack up
so i've been looking at the detailed
information
testing um the the figures i've met with
heathrow so i'll try and understand what
they're doing and pushing them
to make sure that in the end you don't
think it stacks up is there a chance
that you might block it
well look parliament's already voted for
it there are legal cases which might
block it the most important thing and
this will come to in the end to a
government decision which will be made
by another minister not me within the
department
um they will have to uh weigh up whether
um this meets all the tests the
environmental tests johnson of course
famously said he was going to lie down
in front of the bulldozers to stop it
happening he doesn't need to lie down in
front of bulldozers now he can just tell
him to go the other way so
do you think he well i think he i mean
also now since that time which was
several years ago parliament has voted
for it
as a democrat there are a number of
legal challenges some of which have just
been dismissed 26 different cases
so if things have moved on but now what
we want to do is make sure this thing
ends up not costing the the air
passenger
you know a lot of money because they
overspent on the project so i think it's
a question of keeping a very close eye
on okay
now boris johnson of course meeting two
donald's today at the g7 uh donald trump
and later on donald tusk which might be
a little bit more of a
thorny meeting shall we say than the one
he had over breakfast with a u.s
president um
donald tusk says that boris johnson
shouldn't be known as mr no deal brexit
if there is a no deal your department is
going to be
incredibly effective doesn't it because
of the bottleneck through dover
primarily i mean we've been talking
about huge cues we've been talking about
food shortages
potentially having to stockpile medicine
shortages of food
i mean are you worried about all this
it's not just bumps in the road
so i mean it's three years after i was a
remain voter it's three years later and
we're still not left
people actually want to see an end to
this so they won't be an end to it but
they also don't want to see too much
disruption so let me answer your point
so people want to see an end to it and
you're absolutely right
that the department of transport is
absolutely at the front
sort of leading edge of whatever happens
next particularly with those potential
cues
in kent so um i am as i mentioned before
attending
daily um exit operation meetings in
cobra
where we are getting into really
infinitesimal detail
about every possible aspect we will be
ready in fact i would say we are much
more prepared than most people
realize i've been down to dover and
going back over to
calais we're working with the you
weren't surprised at how much of our
trade goes through david that means a
lot of our trade but
here's the secret most people don't
realize the french and europe
export to us way more than we send to
them
so whilst you could if you're in france
say actually we're going to really show
we're going to really make this
demonstrate the point here
we're going to cause those cues um
throughout kent because the answer is
they won't be
sending us and selling us stuff at the
same time so that should be hugely
disadvantageous now
i can't guarantee there won't be delays
i've set up
there will be operation brock we'll see
what happens i've set up this operation
brock
which means that if there are delays
that unlike with stack
the previous operation we can still have
traffic
flowing in both directions we will be as
prepared i want to squeeze in a very
very quick question at the end
because you developed the infamous
spreadsheet that correctly predicted
exactly the number of mps who would vote
for boris johnson
are you the new spreadsheet film i don't
think that's the case
i do think that you know actually it's
there's a wider
message to this which is if you really
plan in detail and if you do things on
spreadsheets for example
you can sound like a better chance of
dealing with things like
the upshot of brexit and that is what
this government's doing okay quan chip
chaps uh thank you very much for being
on the program